makes patrick so amazing i mean for
starters i mean you could go into the
physical attributes that pat has he's
got everything you possibly want
i mean
his arm strength is is unbelievable but
just the different arming the things
he's able to do i know people talk about
you know his no-look passes and all that
but to be able to change his arm angle
you can see why he was such an
incredible athlete in baseball and
basketball as well he's just able to do
things that a lot of quarterbacks can't
do i mean obviously it's cool to get to
play against him and such a big game in
the playoffs and everything like that um
knowing him for a long time uh since i
was a senior in high school
and uh to be able to play on this stage
is going to be special and i mean he
went to oklahoma texas tech so he got
the better of me in college so i'll try
to do my best to win in the nfl
baker on patrick patrick on baker they
once got together in 2016 and put up
66-59 as the final score have a feeling
it will not be quite as dramatic this
time but peter threshold question if
you're the browns what would you
recommend that they do would you
recommend they get into a shootout with
the kansas city chiefs and just try to
score more than the inevitable 30 plus
that kansas city will put on the board
or
do you slow it down
do you run the ball do you tell baker
mayfield you're not a gunslinger you're
a game manager today take the clock down
to one second every time before you snap
it and let's keep patrick with homes on
the sidelines let's limit his
possessions that's the only way we're
going to limit his points which way
would you go
well mike i'm not sure that this team
kansas city the way they ended the
season playing is going to be any wild
west shootout kind of team i mean
the last time that patrick holmes played
they beat the 4 and 12 atlanta falcons
to 14.
uh and they played close games for the
last two months of the season they
haven't blown anybody out for 10 weeks
that's not all the fault of the of the
offense obviously they've had some very
good offensive games
but i think the thing i would i would
say most of all i think there's a
glaring weakness
or there has been in the kansas city
defense they allowed four and a half
yards
uh per rush this year it's in the bottom
10 of the nfl
um what cleveland traditionally has done
best
all season
is you know run two excellent running
backs adam you know and kareem hunt
returning to the scene of his prime
at some point i'll get tired of using
that cliche
but uh kareem hunt and nick chubb
in essence
you know both
either one of them could have a field
day in this game and i'm not saying i'm
sure i'm positive
that steve spagnolo
and the rest of that coaching staff
understands exactly what they're up
against they know that the cleveland
browns run it well so to me
i would try to make this a running game
if i were cleveland and i would try to
limit patrick mahomes to eight
possessions
yeah and look you you mentioned
something earlier this week that i think
is extremely relevant the fact that the
chiefs had the bye week and shut it down
for patrick mahomes and a few other key
starters in week 17. they got to fire up
the engine again against the browns team
that is coming off one of the biggest
one clearly the biggest win since the
browns returned to the nfl in 1999 but
even if you factor in the old browns who
are now the ravens this is one of the
biggest wins in like 40 years for the
browns franchise that's a ton of
momentum going against a team that
hasn't played a meaningful game in three
weeks peter
and i think it's a i think it's a really
really interesting point i and
you don't know how that's gonna that's
gonna
affect this game
but i bet if you ask aaron rodgers going
back to the year that they were whatever
15 and 1 and then lost to the giants in
green bay after resting starters in week
15
and then you know if you if you go back
and ask peyton manning
uh
about resting a couple of those times in
indianapolis when they had to buy
i just
i'm just not sure that when you're not
injured
when you're fine physically and again
who knows patrick mahomes might have had
four
little nicks that he said that andy reid
said i'd rather have him just get
totally healthy for the playoffs if so
that's fine i don't know if that's the
case i have no reason to think it is or
it isn't all i'm saying is in that
situation of course i'd rest him but if
not i just don't like teams and key
players
having been off for 20 days and and look
i will bet you a lot of money mike that
the story after this game if if kansas
city plays very well
that the story will come out that andy
reid practiced them as hard as he's
practiced them all year
in their off week
you know to try to get them back into
offensive rhythm
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports